au cours des quatre jours à venir la
ville d'annecy donne rendez vous à tous
les amateurs de cinéma d'animation ses
quatrièmes rencontres accueille cette
année des réalisateurs et des
concepteurs de talent tels que fritz
frais langue le créateur de sylvestre le
chat et de la panthère rose
rené laloux my view c'est paul grimault
six rencontres propose également de
prendre connaissance de l'oeuvre en
totalité d'un pays voisin la yougoslavie
il sera donc possible de découvrir
l'évolution du dessin animé croate après
de louables efforts le cinéma
d'animation arrivent peu à peu
intéresser le grand public et voit enfin
son impact de progresser
je pense que le cinéma des nations
commence à devenir très populaire prend
son long métrage qui sont plus nombreux
qu'autrefois grâce à la télévision et
aux nouveaux médias la casse fait et
tout ça mais il reste quand même tout un
travail à faire de divulgation notamment
des films de court métrage qui sont
assez mal distribuées et c'est le rôle
d'erica de remplir ce créneau que la
distribution classique ne remplit pas et
si vous pensez que les gens sont friands
de ce genre de spectacle annecy et des
cinéphiles annécien l'ont déjà prouvé et
dans beaucoup d'autres villes on voit
que les gens aiment ce genre de
spectacle encore faut-il quand même
qu'ils reçoivent suffisamment
d'informations au préalable sur la
diversité très grande des styles et des
propos pour qu'ils apprécient pleinement
ce genre mais je pense que son avenir
est certain comment passe-t-on de la
bande dessinée au cinéma d'animation et
bien
dans la fabrication d'un film
d'animation il y a une
il y à une partie qui ressemble beaucoup
à la fabrication d'une bande dessinée
c'est la fabrication de
story board ont rebondi de jeu découpage
décidé découpage dessiner les rôles
le découpage du slim dessinée plan par
plan votre film vient de sortir il est
en exploitation est ce que vous avez des
premiers résultats satisfaisants la
critique à peu près unanime
enfin très enthousiastes les chiffres
d'affaires de se porter très bien
vous êtes content que des villes puis
comme annecy s'intéresse justement à
promouvoir des festivals c'est très
important pour le cinéma d'animation de
s'éloigner de sortir du ghetto dans
lequel il est généralement confinées
c'est à dire c'est important qu'ils
aient du compte que le cinéma
d'animation qui contact avec le grand
public
le festival et promotions dans mon
esprit festival d'annecy égale
animations ça toujours vu de mon côté
qui fit pas un professionnel qui est
vraiment le grand public s'est toujours
considéré festival d'annecy
ah ben ça sonne festival mondial de
l'animation